sociale des gros nuages au dessus de la
compagnie air france elle affiche 3
millions de pertes au premier trimestre
de l'année 93 et un plan de rigueur se
profile à l'horizon
on sera sans doute fixé demain yannick
letranchant sale temps pour la compagnie
air france la rumeur ne court plus elle
vole on ne parle que d'économie de
suppressions d'emplois de plan social
rien d'officiel mais la menace plane
depuis quelques temps déjà
air france doit diminuer les avantages
acquis air france doit mieux se gérer
c'est le combat qui a été mené avec deux
plans de redressement ils ont été
insuffisants parce qu la situation
mondiale s'est encore dégradée il y aura
un nouveau plan de redressement à air
france c'est la survie de notre pavillon
national qui est en jeu ce serait donc
le troisième plan social depuis 1991 les
deux précédents ont déjà supprimé 5000
emplois on parle aujourd'hui de
nouvelles économies plus de 3 milliards
et 3000 suppressions d'emplois le
transport aérien est toujours en pleines
turbulences la concurrence et sauvage
les avions ne sont pas tous remplis
alors les compagnies se livrent à une
surenchère une surenchère à la baisse
les prix coup de coeur remplissent les
avions pas les caisses d'air france le
déficit se creuse 3 milliards rien qu'au
premier semestre de cette année la
riposte réduire les effectifs trop
facile disait syndic
si on veut gagner des parts de marché on
peut pas indéfiniment jouer sur les
effectifs
je sais bien que c'est un moyen facile à
des cons supprimer un agent ça fait 150
mille francs 210 francs d'économies sur
les charges sociales
bah c'est plus facile que trouver des
idées justement pour gagner les parts de
marché un nouveau pari voit le jour pour
la direction imposer plus de rigueur en
évitant une forte agitation sociale pari
dangereux pour elles une journée de
grève lui coûte 80 millions de francs